me mohamed vous avez gagné hier vous
êtes le champion d'ailleurs vous allez
remettre votre titre en jeu dans un
instant vous savez que le champion peut
poser la question à qui il veut vous
avez une question me poser apparemment
aujourd'hui une question qui attendait
tous les fans de tpm paie tous les
téléspectateurs et d'ailleurs sur
twitter hier ça fait couler beaucoup
d'encre on attend cette question grill
j'ai gagné beaucoup de choses hier le
respect des français le droit de vous
poser cette question
mais attention je vous connais pas dans
ton loup je veux la vérité les yeux dans
les yeux pers tu as parlé j'ai parlé et
deux jours au bout de deux jours après
la pagaille peut rester normal dans
cette émission m'a dit mon voisin mon
frère donc pas de pitié pitié pas de
langue de bois parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'au fil des années vous
êtes un peu truqués risée vous aimez
tout le monde
tout le monde est sympa tout le monde
est votre ami votre frère j'en fais
partie mais c'est vrai oui donc ne me
décevez pas dit la vérité
parmi tous les invités que vous avez
reçus s'il fallait me donner le top 3 de
ce que vous avez détesté
oh là là j'adore déjà alors s'est
brouillée
mais d'ailleurs me tourner vers touba
d'abord que des amis à mon avis non aux
seuls amis proches ou de la tam qui est
un ferment en hausse à thomas touré
répondu à cette question toi dans ta
situation c'est très délicat
c'est vrai c'est très délicat moi je
penses que tu peux laisser des indices
mais pas dire alors je vais laisser des
indices en terre enquête exclusive
bernard bernard de la villardière
s'assume pas de surprise non osmose
lieberman la villardière c'est mon choix
a demandé 3 dont bernard de la
villardière ensuite eu alors y aura
tellement pizza et ça monsieur des
pizzas 1 ce qui dit le monsieur des
pizzas jamais reçu de zagallo ici lo'jo
trop facile mais ça y est ça y est plus
à ses adversaires un à l'amiable
s'arrange on savait que tôt ou tard ça
change
alors non je vais dire christophe
beaugrand moins bonne ce vide laissé des
indices
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en fait tu es jeune tu arrives et michel
cymes vivez vous la meilleure vague de
ce début les gens c'est très dur pour
vous avez dit donner des indices mais
que le gars il sort pourtant elle n'est
pas fort on a dit que le ballon se
déplace jeudi